[Musique]
les deux mains dans la terre florence
fois-ci et n'a jamais été aussi heureuse
de jardiner et avec raison ce lopin de
terre au jardin communautaire du parc
goodlands à verdun elle l'attend depuis
trois ans je plante des plantes
médicinales depuis vraiment longtemps et
puis je voulais montrer s'en méfie sauf
quand au troisième étage avec un balcon
fait qu'on n'a pas du tout accès à des
jardins en 2019 elle s'inscrit sur la
liste d'attentes du jardin tous les ans
j'ai appelé mes pieds la bonne nouvelle
est tombée il ya quelques semaines
florence fait partie des 8500
montréalais qui pourront bénéficier d'un
jardinet cet été dans l'un des quelque
100 jardins communautaires de la ville
jeu super contents tant que film appelé
jour de mon anniversaire
super beau cadeau tous n'ont pas eu
cette chance en attendant son propre
jardiner diane landry est d'une voisine
à cultiver le seuil et qui sait pas
moyen je lève la can madame qu'un malade
j'ai demandé mme henry était remplaçant
30 il n'est pas avare de où on attend le
plus longtemps alors qu'en moyenne les
résidents du quartier doivent patienter
de trois à quatre ans pour leurs
jardinets ceux de côte des neiges notre
dame de grâce doivent s'attendre de 6 à
10 ans
même chose sur le plateau mont royal il
faut compter de sept à dix ans après
l'inscription pour obtenir son bout de
terrain alors que dans les quartiers en
périphérie où l'espace pour jardiner
près de la maison est plus disponible
les temps d'attentes varie entre 1 et 3
ans mais un nouvel engouement pour le
jardinage pourrait changer la donne
d'après un sondage récent de la firme
angus reid plus deux millions de ménages
canadiens souhaitent s'initier au
jardinage en 2022 en plus de succès sont
convertis durant la pandémie et dans 85%
des cas y met ces nouveaux jardiniers
habite en ville
des émotions fortes en ce qui a trait à
la sécurité alimentaire ya deux ans avec
l'étape d'être vide mais depuis ce temps
là des coûts augmentent les coûts
alimentaires augmentent et je pense que
les gens se soucient un peu douché les
ailes du bass montréal investira 10
millions de dollars sur 10 ans dans des
projets d'agriculture urbaine
l'enveloppent prévoit l'amélioration des
jardins communautaires existants mais la
ville ne misera plus seulement sur cette
formule à l'avenir est ce que dans ce
contexte de crise du logement ça serait
décent de prendre un terrain municipal
pour faire un jardin communautaire
alors qui peut être utilisé pour du
logement social sur le plateau la
réponse est non et les espaces verts
comme les parcs répondent déjà à
d'autres besoins on a aussi besoin
d'espacé pour corps et se détendre par
des techniques ou autres sans négliger
le modèle des jardins communautaires
morial veut se concentrer davantage sur
le jardinage collectif dans des lieux
publics ou avec des organismes un modèle
qui a fait ses preuves à laval où il est
majoritaire
tout est commun donc les gens ce que
plaide entretiennent l'ensemble du
jardin et partage la collecte en fin
d'année c'est hyper festif le sait très
rassembleur on est attaché au modèle de
jardins communautaires parce que c'est
une formule unique extraordinaire mais
on sait qu'il ya un tel défi avec les
listes d'attentes qu'on développe en
mode collectif c'est pas tout le monde
qui est capable d'aller cultiver un
jardin communautaire
montréal veut ainsi diversifier l'accès
à l'agriculture urbaine elle propose
aussi aux jardiniers de partager une var
celles d'un jardin communautaire
elle incite les montréalais à cultiver
d'autres espaces comme leurs balcons et
va même jusqu'à planter des arbres
fruitiers tout en continuant
d'entretenir ces jardins communautaires
cette part a dit ça fait vraiment du
bien chiche je reviens à la maison je
suis tout crotté mais c'est ça c'est
l'fun pour florence peu importe la
méthode l'important c'est contact avec
la terre
ici elisa la radio canada montréal
[Musique]